the travel restrictions for continental
Europe also caught US airlines by
surprise
Kris Van Cleave is at Reagan National
Airport that's outside Washington DC
Chris good morning
a lot of confusion overnight about what
exactly this order meant so try to parse
it for us what happened and what does it
mean for American travelers well good
morning there was confusion because
initially it sounded like the president
had banned all travel of people and
goods from Europe to the US that caught
even members of his own administration
and the airline's off guard there was
then an effort overnight to clarify what
had been said first by the Department of
Homeland Security and then the White
House for American travelers here's what
you need to know Americans will still be
allowed to travel to and from Europe
they will be allowed to come into the
country but they will be subject to
health screenings likely and be funneled
to the 11 airports currently doing those
screenings for other coronavirus
hotspots basically the president's
orders very similar to the one that was
put into effect for travelers from China
so here anyone who is a resident of the
countries in Europe that is not a US
citizen will not be allowed to come into
the u.s. for the next 30 days at least
now that does not apply to u.s. citizens
as we said but there was a lot of
confusion about that point Anthony all
right Chris the the head of JetBlue who
was with us yesterday said that even
before these restrictions Chris in the
impact was already worse than 9/11 so
what what are these restrictions gonna
do do you think for the airlines yeah
that was a pretty telling statement from
Robin Hayes yesterday on CBS this
morning the airlines are worried and
this is not good for their bottom line
already global airlines are facing an
estimated hundred-plus billion dollars
in losses from the coronavirus US
airlines are now scrambling to figure
out what this means for their a
transatlantic service that's usually a
profit Center certainly we have seen
demand plummet on US airlines already
one european carrier has gone out of
business and if we're talking about an
impact similar to what the 9/11 attacks
did to the airline business that pushed
several US airlines into bankruptcy this
is not good news and just last night of
JetBlue flight from JFK to Palm Beach
had a passenger who tested positive for
corona virus that was
yet another scare for flyers in that
case it was taken to an isolated part of
the Palm Beach Airport that passenger
was removed the people on board are now
being asked to self monitor Tony empty
all right thanks Chris